big news breaking this afternoon out of
kenosha wisconsin a jury cleared kyle
rittenhouse of all five charges in a
shooting that took place during a night
of protests and violence in the summer
of 2020. the jury returned its verdict
after almost three and a half days of
deliberation about 26 hours worth 18
year old rittenhouse could have faced
life in prison if he was found guilty of
the most serious charge against him
so let's bring in ayan main he is a
professor at university of wisconsin law
school in madison to give us some
instant analysis on the verdict
professor maine welcome to quick take i
want to start obviously with whether
this acquittal was surprising to you or
whether it's something you anticipated
legally
it's not unexpected and is troubling and
it's certainly within the realm of what
we could expect legally why is that
because what the self-defense
instruction is is it gives a lot of
discretion to the jury it's really a
community standard it helps reflect
where we are about what we think is
reasonable when it comes to
using deadly force to defend ourselves
and so there's no guidance in the law as
to
what that is what that point of
reasonableness is it really is a
community decision and so it
certainly can reflect who we are at the
moment in terms of
how our encounters go and what we can
expect from those encounters in terms of
how much discretion people have
to use deadly force against others
if that's the case tell us a little bit
about kenosha kenosha is not the same as
madison what kind of community is
kenosha that would interpret
self-defense this specific way
that's a really interesting question and
you're right that the juries in
different places might have a different
approach right to the same question of
reasonableness and
just in terms of a general comment
quickly gets here just but this is a 17
year old when he did it so i think as
any kind of jury is going to take that
into consideration that the fact that
matter this is a 17 year old that would
be different than if this is a 30 year
old male to your question
kenosha is a more conservative kind of
environment than madison is so
to your point it is a reflection of the
community standard and this could
certainly have gone a different way if
this was in a different jurisdiction
like madison which is in dane county is
more liberal so if i'm hearing you
correctly you're basically saying that
what self-defense means pretty much
depends on
who the jury is and where this case is
taking place where the trial is
occurring
i think that's the case and that that's
certainly the case with other matters
too when you're talking about what is
reasonable
um but i think it also reflects as part
of the national
kind of consensus about
what use of force is in terms of deadly
force and it might be different as
you're suggesting in california that it
might be in texas
i by the way i just want to point out
that we're looking at live pictures of
the courthouse in kenosha this is right
outside the courthouse there are some
protesters there they've been there
since the beginning
since the jury began deliberations there
is some police presence but as far as
i've checked there hasn't been any kind
of physical
conflict
that has been reported thus far but
we'll keep you posted on any
developments there again live photos of
the courthouse in kenosha wisconsin um
professor
given that he was acquitted of all
charges why do you think this particular
case was so divisive i mean it was
something that everyone in the nation
talked about hedge fund billionaires
including bill ackman were tweeting
their impressions of how rittenhouse
presented when he was testifying
well i mean that was its own separate
big moment right i mean i think what the
defense had tried to do was in pre-trial
proceedings try to get a use of force
expert to testify as to whether or not
this is reasonableness and reasonable
and if they had successfully done so
they probably would not have put mr
rittenhouse on the stand the judge
didn't permit that use of force experts
so
having a defendant especially 18 year
old take the stand on national tv
regarding such you know an issue that
everyone is focused on is a really big
moment a big risk for the defense so
everyone was definitely thinking about
that looking at that and trying to
analyze what it means i think he did a
good job but a separate from that is the
kind of social precedent that this sets
that this case sets and i think it
emboldens those who believe that if they
have open carry
who carry writes that they actually in
my mind have more discretion to use
deadly force than someone who is unarmed
and i think that is really a dangerous
precedent
yeah that's a really good point i just
wonder how does this case help clarify
our understanding of how the law defines
self-defense and how a jury might
interpret it or perhaps it doesn't
clarify it and it just only muddies it
i think it just reflects where we are we
have a use of force expert again who was
asked if mr rosenbaum in that first
incident um who had a plastic bag and
aggressing say on mr rittenhouse if
that had happened and mr rittenhouse did
not have a weapon that was unarmed
would it have been justified for mr
rittenhouse to use deadly force against
mr rosenbaum and the answer to the
expert was no and i think that should be
a chilling response because are we
considering the possibility that someone
with a gun
has more discretion to use deadly force
than an unarmed person toward another
and that's really what this trial
reflects and i think that should be the
point we should be discussing do we want
to give more rights to use deadly force
to someone who is carrying a weapon than
if they are unarmed the answer from the
written house trial is yes
i think the answer should be no but this
is a debate that we're actually having
now
yeah and i mean if if the answer is yes
that it makes you kind of question
everything from here on out in terms of
what the possibilities are
i wonder as well
written house is white the victims were
white
yet race was always present in this in
this trial it was almost like an
undercurrent
how do you think that might have
influenced the trial or maybe it didn't
i would say race uh always influences a
trial
because if it's a person of color
there's going to be different dynamics
that are going to
be disfavorable toward a defendant of
color i mean i've been
a criminal defense lawyer for long
enough now to see
um the dynamics are very the strategies
or the outcome that we expect are
going to be affected by a lot of things
right but race is always one of them the
defense knew this in this case
and the defense would know it if the
defendant here had been
a person of color it would change the
dynamics it would change the narrative
about who gets to carry weapons um this
is one of those ideas that this white
kid was a good kid
and should be carrying a weapon but you
don't get that in a lot of cases where
there's a self-defense instruction and
and the defendant is a person of color
who had a gun
and so our narratives really very much
are influenced by
race even if it's not conscious that
we're doing it it's absolutely as you
say kind of in the background and
certainly shaping the conversation i
think that's interesting what you said
about how the defendant was kind of seen
as a good kid that was kind of like the
default setting from the beginning
as you mentioned the defense did put him
on the stand how do you think he
presented i remember when he testified a
lot of people made the comment that he
was
crying he was upset and
there was a lot of empathy for him
because of that and yes he's young he's
18 years old now he was 17 when the
incident happened how do you think he
presented overall
i think he presented really well i mean
i think when you're thinking about
putting a defendant on the stand you
always don't want to do it that's the
default kind of position but again this
is one of the situations where the
defense didn't feel like they had a
whole lot of choice in the matter
they needed a response or an
interpretation from the defendant's
point of view
um and so
he did amazingly well for an 18 year old
and the fact of the matter is that he
cried or or expressed a certain amount
of of kind of remorse to
the jury and it wouldn't maybe not even
remorse right but being really affected
by it is important you never want a
defendant
being up there and angry that's just
like the worst kind of
case scenario for a defense attorney and
that was not the case with mr riddenhaus
he did not come across as angry he came
across as someone who was genuine he
thought he was doing the right thing
and you know one expects a more vigorous
cross-examination i think that was the
weakest day
for the prosecution i think the
prosecution could have done a better job
on cross-examination i'm not saying it
could have made a difference in this
case but i was really surprised um about
how the
ineffective the cross-examination was
was of an 18 year old kid by a seasoned
prosecutor
i want to go back to that idea that he
thought he was doing the right thing um
a lot of people questioned why he was
there to begin with he traveled from
illinois to kenosha um to on his own to
take up arms essentially to defend
businesses people there
but that part of what he did was not on
trial right that's not what he was being
charged with it's the action that took
place afterwards
you're exactly right but as you can
expect
both sides are going to
create the circumstances that led to the
incident and that those circumstances
help
influence the jury on how they're going
to determine whether or not say mr
rittenhouse was exercising a reasonable
judgment and so these background factors
do have
some kind of purchase in a case like
this
certainly for some people me included
the fact that
a number of open carry
armed white individuals would show up at
a protest where
over the fact that a black man was shot
seven times in the back by a white
police officer i thought was
really disgusting
and
you know regardless of what you think
your right is you need to take in
consideration the the surrounding
circumstances so
not only was it really really racially
insensitive and causing racial harm by
doing that but then you also escalate a
situation that was already escalating
under the idea that you're there to
ensure order
um so it went while in my mind you're
creating disorder and so you know but
obviously that's my view and there are
opposing views who see the actions of
these individuals as consistent with
law and order and maintaining order and
one can see a history of this too that
there's this idea in the united states a
long kind of history of
police departments being white or
sheriff departments being white
deputizing other white civilians at
various times to create a policing
presence and so this is part of our
history in some respects and and kind of
a
modern day reflection of those
historical
um anchors in our society
interesting i hadn't thought about it
that way
your area of expertise is criminal law
professor main uh policing use of force
issues i know that this is a case that
you had talked about in class with your
students what were some of the biggest
discussion points in class before this
verdict was returned
i mean some of the bigger discussion
points was
actually some of the issues that haven't
been brought up a whole lot like as to
the fact that he's he was a juvenile
when this happened i mean not under the
law of wisconsin but most of us in the
criminal law field and students who are
thinking about this understand that
brain development for a 17 year old
is really not at a point that we should
consider that individual an adult
and so there was a lot of discussion
over the fact that on one hand we're
talking about really important
self-defense issues that are going to
define for adults what self-defense is
and at the same time
you have arguably a kid who's being
prosecuted for this and is it right to
prosecute prosecute a kid for a crime
that could put that child in prison for
the rest of his life or should this be a
juvenile matter
and treat it completely under a
different sort of kind of
punitive philosophy um and so that was a
big discussion one that was not really
being discussed nationally right but
this this idea for people who are kind
of students who are embedded in kind of
criminal justice like
why are we treating this individual as
an adult was a big question and then
allowing a
what happened by a child to define what
the standard is for adults
do you think the jury saw it that way i
mean
were they were they
were they coming up and deliberating
their verdict based on the fact that he
was 17 even though by the time this
trial was taking place he was 18.
yeah and i don't think personally that
the age of the person should matter at
the time of they're being charged
it matters when you do something that's
the whole idea that of the person's
brain development was at when they did
something right and so
um yeah and but i still think you know
the jury i imagine i don't know what
happened no one knows what happened in
the jury room but one could come to the
conclusion that
a reasonable conclusion that the jury
did consider his age i imagine this
would be a different set of
considerations for a jury if this is an
individual who's 30 years old and six
foot two right um
so i you know and and so
uh i definitely think that his age came
into it that was not explicitly made i
actually think the prosecution made some
mistakes here and emphasizing his his
minor status from just a pure
prosecution wine away from the
prosecution side emphasize the fact that
he played video games and things like
that i thought that was a misstep right
why would you emphasize that this is a
kid if you want to bring adult charges
against this person
um but i think it was quite possible for
the jury as you're determining what is
reasonable
for an individual to feel threatened and
thinking about well this is a 17 year
old kid i i could reasonably see that
coming to play in the jury room
ayan thank you so much for joining us
today iron maine is professor at
university of wisconsin law school in
madison he is a specialist in criminal
law policing and use of force commenting
on the written house verdict in which
kyle rittenhouse was cleared of all five
charges thank you so much this is
bloomberg quick take and we want to turn
now to some on the ground coverage in
kenosha wisconsin where bloomberg's
skyler woodhouse is she's been outside
the courthouse and she joins us by phone
skyler good to speak with you where were
you when the verdict came in i was
actually in the courtroom um i it was it
was quite the scene i mean it was it was
dead silent and you know when the when
the decision was coming in the reaction
with kyle's family and the family from
the prostitution they just broke down in
tears um kyle kind of dropped to his
knees and um his attorneys were helping
holding him up um there was just a lot
of emotions um flowing through the
courtroom when those decisions were
coming in how did the jurors look when
they announced the verdict
you know
some of them had masks on and i think
the masks were kind of hiding some of
their facial expressions um i tried
speaking with some of the jurors after
the decision and once everything kind of
died down and you know they were
exported out of the courtroom and they
they didn't respond to any comments um
for myself or other media and i i think
the jury was just kind of ready to be
done and you could kind of feel this
energy from them that they were ready to
go home they wanted to move on they want
to end this close this chapter and move
on which is understandable they
deliberated for about 26 hours
do we know if that's a long time not
enough time i mean what kind of
expectations were there in kenosha for
how long this this verdict would take
yeah i think people you know thought
originally okay maybe there would be a
decision sooner in the week and then
after we kind of progressed and we came
to friday there was a lot of
conversation of oh is this going to
spill into next week would we be called
in on a saturday um but then you know we
got that decision today and it kind of
just like
put everyone to some sort of views in
terms of the the waiting game and and
yeah so i think and no one really knew
when but when we got when we heard it
was time it just yeah
was there could you hear
the reaction outside we're looking at
live pictures right now of a crowd
outside the courthouse there are
definitely people there but it looks
fairly calm i'm sure there's a police
presence as well people have signs up
did you hear the crowd react in any way
yeah so you know
the the crowd is it's not very large and
there will be moments where you know the
crowd might get a little riled up or it
will quiet back down so it kind of goes
back and forth and you know it's just
kind of a matter of what will happen or
someone might say something that might
rile up the other person and then
they'll go back and forth a little bit
but it really has been rather calm out
here i mean when i was in the courtroom
and the decisions came in you could hear
this roar come from outside i mean i
couldn't tell which side it was on but
you could hear the energy from outside
but there was a medical emergency and it
brought some police in and you know it
kind of created um
a lot of commotion but the person was
taken away by the ambulance and the
police been cleared out but so far
things are pretty calm
and are you inside the the courtroom
right now or are you outside
you know i'm outside i've been outside
i'm talking to just you know different
people trying to gather their reactions
and you know what they're thinking and
some people have said that this is kind
of setting the tone for you know the
future and how things might be handled
going forward some people have said that
they are rather surprised when they
heard the decisions coming in so i think
it's a lot of mixed emotions right now
as people still try and process um the
verdict absolutely the guest we're just
speaking with professor main of
university of wisconsin law school in
madison was saying that
the verdict really shows how it depends
on where you are and who you are and how
you interpret self-defense uh the jury
was given wide latitude for what it
means to defend yourself
what do we know about the the protesters
who are out there are they people from
kenosha or are they people who travel to
kenosha from elsewhere in wisconsin or
outside of wisconsin for that matter to
to to protest and to make clear their
views
yeah so it's it's a mix i spoke with
someone who actually came from kyle's
hometown in illinois but then you have
people from wisconsin who are coming
people are really from all over i mean
we i've spoken to people who are from
rhode island so you know people i think
are just kind of are they're trickling
in i spoke with one man who actually
used to live in kenosha and said he
moved out of the city when when all of
the protests and riots were happening um
in summer of 2020 so he's now here today
to kind of just see how things are going
but it's a mix of people and people are
coming people are driving by you know
kind of doing a little drive by taking a
peek at you know what's going on but
but yeah so people are coming in from
all over and they're just really here to
see
what what is happening what's the mood
like in kenosha overall i mean where are
people were people just anticipating
this verdict and looking forward to
there being some kind of resolution no
matter what it was or were they really
animated in terms of what they and an
outcome that they were invested in
you know i i think a lot of people i i
think we think when you talk about the
people of kenosha i think a lot of them
were kind of ready for this to be done
um just i spoken with people who talked
about the media presence and kind of the
attention that it has brought to to
their um hometown so i think a lot of
people in kenosha were ready for this to
be over and and now that it is i think a
lot of people are just ready to go back
to their daily lives absolutely well
you've been a trooper skyler covering
this for us i'm just curious what angle
are you looking to write about next
you're a reporter for bloomberg news
you've been covering the developments
you've been looking at
what kenosha has been doing to prepare
for potential unrest in the wake of the
verdict how are you reporting on this
i think going forward you know i'm
looking at the reaction from people and
how they're feeling are they sad are
they happy like i'm trying to speak with
that many people on both sides of the
aisle to kind of get an understanding of
where their heads at but also i think it
will be really interesting to see how
this case sets the tone for the rest of
the country when dealing with
self-defense cases so that'll be
something to watch going forward
absolutely skyler woodhouse thank you so
much bloomberg news reporter skyler
woodhouse joining us from outside the
courthouse in kenosha wisconsin where
kyle rittenhouse 18 years old was
cleared of all five charges this was
after about 26 hours of deliberation by
the jury this is bloomberg quick take
i'm scarlet fo